des portraits des manuels matheron
décrocher une action non violente avec
un message que murs vides qu'on a laissé
à la place du portrait du président
macron ça illustre le vide de la
politique climatique et sociale de ces
pays qui n'est pas du tout à la hauteur
des enjeux du moment
depuis le début de l'année une
quarantaine de portraits ont été
décrochées dans les mairies un mode
d'action un solide qui se multiplient en
france depuis quelques années
rappelez-vous contre l'évasion fiscale
en 2015 il y a eu les faucheurs de
chaise ces militants investissez les
banques et s'emparait des chaises
là encore une action symbolique avec un
message je suis en train de reprendre le
bien de l'état c'est-à-dire son parti du
mobile double-play derrière ces actions
des associations militante écologiste et
altermondialiste busy actions non
violentes comme 21 ou encore alternatiba
un des cofondateurs expliqué d'ailleurs
en 2015 le fondement de ce militantisme
qui s'inscrit dans la tradition de la
non violence
c'est aux citoyens maintenant de créer
la différence et d'agir et on pense
qu'il faut agir de manière à la fois non
violente et déterminée la non-violence
théorisée par gandhi reprise par martin
luther king les exemples que l'histoire
nous donne montre le pouvoir et
l'efficacité de la non-violence sit-in
blocage fauchage ou encore aujourd'hui
décrochage pour apprendre ces techniques
de désobéissance civile des stages sont
organisés
c'est pour montrer qu'on peut
empêcher c'est son âge pour la lgv etc
et d'autres réactions peut-être futur
qui pourront aborder plus tard mais
notamment ses actions contre et se
pacifiquement les militants profite de
chaque interpellation et de chaque
jugement pour diffuser leur message
je suis poursuivi pour vol en réunion en
fait nous on a jamais appeler ça un vol
le on pense que ce sont les banques qui
organise un vol à très grande échelle
des finances publiques
ces militants assurent que les
décrochages de portrait vont continuer
objectif en avoir 125 d'ici la réunion
du g7 à biarritz fin août
125 soit le nombre de jours qu'il a
fallu à la france en 2019 pour consommer
au-delà de ces ressources
[Musique]